make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and uh i didn't intend to upload
this video until
monday but i changed my mind and so what
we're doing here is we are covering
maestro part two part dos and this is
this is actually really cool right
it's written by peter david he's the guy
who created maestro so it's only fitting
that he's the one that actually does
this i'm still waiting for the story to
beef up a bit one of the things about
peter david that you guys need to know
right
those are guys out there who are not
really familiar with peter david one of
the things you need to know is peter
david takes his time when it comes to
writing a story right and a lot of
writers do but that's because peter
david's old school right jonathan
hickman kind of writes in the vein of
the old school writers it's one of the
reasons why
hickman is really kind of hit and miss
is that if you love like the long drawn
out kind of story like the old claremont
stories or the old peter david
incredible hulk run or something like
that then you love hickman if you like
the more modern era of stories like
donnie cates or or somebody like jeff
lemire whereas things are just happening
pretty consistently and pretty fast then
it's going to be a little bit of a turn
off and peter david's the same way
right if you like the kind of fast-paced
shotgun style of storytelling that you
get now then he's not really the writer
for you but if you're like me
and you like the more drawn out story
where it takes a little while to tell a
set of events and then you're a fan of
that right with my show it's a little
bit different because this is basically
a mini series it's only five issues long
but this one picks up
really with my show just kind of talking
about how he hoped
that modoc was exaggerating right when
modoc talked about how humanity had
basically obliterated itself that he was
hoping he was exaggerating that he was
basically lying because that's what bad
guys do
and then he basically says like he
wasn't right like that we as people
think we know ourselves right we think
we know what we're capable of we think
we understand the upper limits of what
human cruelty can be and then we somehow
find a way to exceed those limits and
that's basically what he realized that
mount rushmore itself has been totally
destroyed hoover dam was completely
wiped out and all
you know the various cities around it
were all completely flooded that las
vegas was totally trashed and the kind
of comments that not even he as joe
fixit probably could have done anything
about this which is true
just nuclear bombs following i mean
we'll not believe in nuclear bombs the
way this devastation looks
and that's what so what's kind of crazy
about this when the original future
imperfect story came out we were kind of
given this set of events where it looked
like it was the result
of a nuclear war that had broken out
across the world
but none of this looks like nuclear
damage because when you're talking about
a nuclear bomb detonating one
nuclear bombs don't actually hit the
ground they detonate above the ground to
maximize the amount of damage that can
be done and two because you probably
take the risk of just creating a
colossal crater on the surface of the
world if you detonate a nuclear bomb at
ground zero and then
two usually because of the destructive
blast whether it's because of like the
sheer impact of the nuclear bomb or the
massive amount of heat that it lets off
none of these buildings would really be
standing right and so this looks like
just conventional bombs right
conventional weaponry but you know it's
one of these things where it doesn't
really look like atomic explosions no
more so than that while there is this
indication of radiation it may be one of
these things where
when it came to smaller places or not
really smaller places some places
received nuclear bomb and you know
nuclear bombardment other places didn't
right so whatever the case is the idea
of radiation is given to us in two ways
the first
is because the you know maestro ends up
coming across some animals who had
basically died of what looked like
radiation poisoning right they didn't
realize the plants that they were eating
and the the water they were consuming
was irradiated right and so they
basically ended up dying from that but
from there he kind of ends up taking off
one thing to bear in mind
maestro has not become the maestro that
we know right he's not like the dark
twisted character at this point he's
still just the incredible hulk and one
of the cornerstones of the hulk's
character was that he was largely a
peaceful character until you pissed him
off right but like if you just left him
alone and he was just kind of wandering
out there in the wilderness by himself
he was very peaceful and very calm
because he likes to just kind of be left
alone right that's kind of peter david
referencing his work bill mantlo's work
roy thomas's work the idea of the
incredible hulk just likes to be left in
peace uh that's the old school
incredible hulk stuff but regardless
while he's there and he ends up seeing
that basically the washington monument
is is you know almost totally destroyed
and this is kind of what i'm talking
about like it looks like uh washington
dc
was hit with a nuclear bomb just because
of the sheer lack of anything
surrounding the washington monument you
have like stuff like the lincoln
monuments there just because it was
built so well like it would it would
withstand a nuclear bombardment nobody
would live who was there but like it
would be able to withstand it
but he ends up seeing this kid who's
running off now the kid jumps down a
trapdoor and he in turn follows suit
right and this is one of the funny
things about the hulk because as soon as
soon as he gets down there you have all
these guys who just kind of like freeze
right like stop where you're good you
know stop or will shoot he's like okay
i've got an itch on my back like if you
guys don't mind focusing your fire there
it'll definitely help like it'll
definitely make me feel better
and that's what he's meant by the
arrival of aaron stack right machine man
and aaron stack always seems to find a
way to survive now here's a funny thing
about this i think if i'm being if i'm a
betting man
if i'm being honest with you guys i
think this is because of earth x
i really think that's the reason why
right aaron stack was
never really a relevant or interesting
character before
earth x right before that story was done
you know before alex ross did that it
was
never and he was never an interesting
character but that story kind of gave us
like this crazy looking you know
dystopian future from the perspective of
the
of the watcher uatu and aaron stack
himself right and that's kind of what
catapulted him into being a pretty
popular character in more recent years
it's been what's going on in the iron
man comics which still doesn't make him
any more interesting but he's kind of a
guy that always
basically ends up making it and what we
end up finding out here is that the you
know
the white house has been totally
destroyed right i mean it's it's
standing but it's just been
nobody survived right the president the
vice president the cabinet's congress
they're all gone right like they're
they're all
they're all basically dead uh and those
individuals who survived that
bombardment have taken refuge in the
bunkers below
washington dc and they just kind of
lived there ever since right they've had
their children and and so on and so
forth and it's just people who live but
the other thing about this
is that the idea of there being an
ordered government is basically gone
right there really is no government
anymore it's just survivors and this is
an important thing and the reason why is
because there's all kinds
of philosophical story or philosophical
papers and stuff like that that are
being written about what happens when
society returns to a state of nature
which is to say a world with no ordered
government whatsoever
and one of the things they kind of hit
at and really even with thomas hobbs was
kind of like a perpetual and permanent
war of all against all like basically a
constant war over resources but
regardless of who you go with the
general consensus is that if something
like that were to happen right we were
to have some kind of war take place in
the u.s
and there's no ruling faction there's no
federal organization that's
basically governing over the american
people then what you would see is a rise
of strong men right and petty warlords
and that's it right just
individuals out there who were strong
enough to just kind of maintain their
own region
and then somebody may come along with
the power to overtake them and then they
would take that region from them and
then rule it themselves right that's all
you would really see
you really wouldn't see the restoration
of a government or anything like that
and that's kind of the story of the
maestro
you know basically kind of looking at
this and realizing this is dystopia now
dystopia is in the remnants of what used
to be new york right but the other thing
about this is that once the incredible
hulk leaves and
you know he's basically told like the
person who governs over dystopia at the
moment
his name is maestro right so there's a
person named maestro governing over
dystopia at the moment you know he's
like okay i've got to meet this guy
right and so he ends up kind of taking
off and then starts to succumb to
radiation not in the sense that it kills
him but in the sense that it makes him
dizzy and it makes him a little
exhausted and he kind of starts
to pass out but then suddenly he hears
this weird buzzing sound from out of
nowhere and it's like these giant bugs
that show up and basically start
consuming him or start attacking him now
this is peter david referencing his own
story
incredible hulk the end right i don't
know if you guys ever read that story
it's depressing it's
good but it's so sad right like a little
bit of a sidetrack here incredible hulk
the end was a story very similar to this
right where basically war had broken out
across the world and pretty much all the
superheroes had died
and pretty much all of humanity had died
right there wasn't really anybody else
it was just the incredible hulk and
uh and his bruce banner persona and the
bruce banner persona was growing old and
basically kind of you know
dying more or less but it was the
incredible hulk still holding on to his
hatred for banner and so there comes a
point when the banner persona ends up
dying right like of old age he just dies
of a heart attack and so the banner
persona dies and the incredible hulk's
the only one left and he's just like
hulk is alone and he is the incredible
hulk is the only survivor on earth
everything else is gone there's no
humans
no nothing right just the incredible
hulk but over the course of that story
one of the things that happens is these
giant bugs descend on him every single
day and completely and totally consume
him
and then he just ends up regrowing
because of his healing factor like he he
deals with that
every single day it's it's it's really
dark but it is
incredibly good it's it's an amazing
story but
unlike what we saw in hulk the end
maestro is not totally consumed instead
these kind of sonic waves come out of
nowhere and then basically chase off
these various bugs only for the
incredible hulk to basically be rescued
by a handful of individuals now once he
comes to
once he wakes up at their location we
find out these are the wasteland
survivalists right from the from the
future imperfect story these are the
folks that have basically made their way
and survived and what are considered the
wastes which is to say the territories
out there that don't really have any
kind of ordered government and don't
really have any radiation
the biggest issue these folks have to
cope with are bandits right just bandits
who show up here try to ransack their
stuff and then leave right that's the
biggest issue they have to cope with but
with maestro kind of looking out onto
the horizon and then basically seeing
dystopia then his question is like is
that dystopia and they're told yes like
you know he's and
and you know the hulk says tell me about
maestro and these the guy's like they
say he's god
and so he's like okay now i gotta meet
this guy now from here we pick up with
rick jones
now rick jones as he's shown here is
kind of a character who's just there uh
but because this goes
you know seemingly into future imperfect
rick jones was an exceedingly important
character right but you see him using
all these little knickknacks you know
kind of having all these little
artifacts right he's got like bucky
barnes arm
back there in the background right he's
got the head of vision he's got
spider-man mask he's got thor's hammer
he's got you know uh magneto's uh
magneto's helmet you know there's the
body of wolverine he just got all these
little things here and there right like
all these little these little trinkets
and so on that basically he just kind of
collects but he ends up being met by
janus now of course janice was
also an important character in the
future in perfect storyline and i'm kind
of waiting to see where peter david goes
with this because if he ends up
basically offering an explanation it
would be redundant to do it here but if
in the next few issues he doesn't then
i'll make this all make sense right for
these for these characters i might leave
you guys hanging but janice basically
comes in and says like grandpa he's back
and he's like what are you talking about
he's like that great big green hulking
guy that you always talked about he's
like the incredible hulk janice is like
he walked right into town square right
he walked right into downtown
as big as life and so it's like okay so
like
the incredible hulk's back right now at
that point we switched back over to hulk
himself and kind of walking around
and looking at everything and just being
like god this used to be times square at
one point
how crazy is it how far humanity has
fallen
so fast right like we went from like
this technologically advanced
society or at least you know relatively
advanced to basically being like this
hodgepodge community where folks are
just barely making it by and so he tells
one of the people like i want to meet
the maestro and he's told like nobody
meets the maestro right he's like do i
look like nobody you know and so like
this emissary kind of pops out of
nowhere and says like i'm the minister
right i'm the minister of the maestro
the maestro dispatched me to bring you
to him right the maestro wants to meet
you and so that's when you end up having
hulk following this guy and as he gets
in there it's obvious that dystopia
exists in two different ways
basically people who are out there in
dystopia the downtrodden barely making
it by
and then you've got the maestro in his
territory and you've got people who
basically live
in more or less opulence right i mean
they just kind of live and they're
carefree and you know they obviously
have enough to eat different things like
that so they're not really struggling
it's very reminiscent of the kind of
issues you see
when it's like the upper class versus
the lower class right you see like the
czars of russia you know in years past
and like all the people who were there
which eventually gave rise to the
bolsheviks right the balsa revolution
the eradication or the execution of the
tsarist family which gave birth to like
leninist communism and and you know
vladimir lenin leon trotsky and then
eventually joseph stall and all that
kind of stuff but like that's kind of
what you see here
this super high class versus the super
low class which always leads to
revolution and so what you end up having
is the incredible hulk greeted by the
maestro and he's like banner like i'm so
glad to see you
it's been an age and we end up finding
out the person ruling over everybody
right now
is none other than hercules meaning the
incredible hulk is gonna fight hercules
which is gonna be amazing with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you